vous avez 65 ambre je vois le coeur d'un
homme de 75 ans a marqué à 75 ans on
peut vivre longtemps sans femme
chauffait basses aux foules c'est ça et
surtout sans alcool ça va être la belle
lui
je sais que tout barry t'attends tu
adores publie vous admire g je vous aime
vraiment beaucoup j'ai envie d'arrêter
tout le th reçu des mains j'ai envie
de léo porte anr
bien on va prendre un verre je peux pas
je suis déjà prises
[Applaudissements]
et puis là les couleurs à la caisse que
des spirites papa jamie green bay
quand donné mais ce qu'il faut pas
toujours espérer
j'ai marié j'ai là
[Musique]
où
ray de lui écrire ça sert à rien ce hors
jeu
[Musique]
tu t'es acheté des nouvelles chaussures
oui quand je le sais
je sais tout de toi
je vois tout de toi
c'est quand le coeur éclate combat
silencieux
au jardin
un sculpteur aimé du vide là où ça va
craquer
faire attendre
ça qui fait manger
[Musique]